[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue à tous dans ce nouveau
débat nous nous pencherons ce soir sur
le phénomène des soldes depuis quelques
années en effet elle semble perdre du
terrain vous l'avez peut-être remarqué
on ne voit plus de pieusse enfin le
premier jour et moins de bousculades
dans les magasins selon plusieurs
sondages
la proportion de français ayant
l'intention de faire les soldes d'hiver
cette année est en diminution par
rapport à l'an dernier et de façon plus
générale seul un français sur cinq se
dit aujourd'hui impatients d'attendre
les soldes
la faute à quoi et bien à plusieurs
facteurs comme la concurrence des offres
promotionnelles proposées tout au long
de l'année
il sera évidemment aussi question du
pouvoir d'achat avec nous pour en
débattre lydia drevon directrice du
centre commercial one nationaux clayes
sous bois et philippe leray président de
l'ufc que choisir de versailles bonsoir
à tous les deux l'histoire
ils tiendront je me tourne vers vous les
soldes ont commencé depuis une semaine
fait mon un petit bilan ça s'est bien
passé pour votre centre commercial
écoutez oui on peut on est très
satisfait du lancement des soldes
mercredi on a progressé de 29% sur le
trafic
il faut savoir que ça reste un grand
moment clé puisque ce week-end nous
avons battu un record d'entrées donc ça
reste encore un moment très très
important pour les clients alors
rappelez nous le concept des soldes donc
ce sont des produits qui doivent être en
rayon depuis un mois a rappelé nos
simplement les règles rapidement
effectivement les règles c'est le
produit doit être présents dans le
magasin le mois précédant le début des
soldes et avoir été vendues très bien
philippe lioret les consommateurs ont de
nouvelles habitudes aujourd'hui est-ce
que ça rentre en jeu dans justement
cette
mais ce qu'étaient les soldes alors je
dirais que c'est complémentaire s'il est
bon les soldes historiquement c'est dans
la tradition des consommateurs deux fois
par an donc de consommer davantage à ce
moment là hein parce que d'importants
moyens de 221 euros par français au
moment des soldes en plus cette année
encore oui effectivement c'est sûr de
cette liste j'ai là ce serait voilà ceci
dit bien évidemment maintenant avec la
communication qui est fait
les 35 sel et des centres commerciaux et
les commerçants les français et
fascinateur savent qu'il ya d'autres
possibilités d'acheter à des prix
réduits à d'autres moments de l'année
comment des sols et les promos les
déstockages les cartes de fidélité
internet donc il ya beaucoup d'autres
moyens qui font la concurrence en fait
un petit peu à la pour acheter deux fois
certes s'alarme rejeté deux fois très
bien est ce qu'il ya une question aussi
de baisse du pouvoir d'achat est ce que
vous sentez encore aujourd'hui que les
consommateurs tout simplement réservent
leurs budgets pour autre chose que de
l'habillement parce que les soldes c'est
quand même principalement fondé la ville
voilà c'est ça c'est mon habillement
alors c'est vrai que je pense que c'est
un temps fort dans le
en achetant un commercial bon il faut
tenir compte aussi du climat évidemment
que quand il fait froid je penserai à me
dire mieux moi mais que les décès
peut-être plus certains articles qui se
vendent que d'autres il me semble l'igad
rebonds en fait c'est intéressant ce
site n parce que ce sont les marques
elles mêmes qui se font un petit peu
concurrence en proposant des ventes
privées ou d'autres formes de
propositions de promotions toute l'année
elle dit souad un peu leurs propres
consommateurs de revenir le jour des
soldes n'ont pas forcément parce que les
soldats portent des des remises
supplémentaires en fait puisque vous
avez le droit de vendre à perte
et c'est la fin de la collection donc
chaque commerçant veut voir sa
collection hiver là pour le moment
partir donc n'hésite pas à mettre une
première démarque une deuxième démarque
et l'appétence des français reste fort
puisqu'il ya quand même 73 % des clients
qui sont présents sur les soldes c'est
vrai mais ce chiffre était de 95% je
crois en 2014 encore donc il ya quand
même une petite diminution mais ça ne se
voit peut-être pas dans votre sens
commercial parce qu'il faut le préciser
vous êtes un outlet donc expliquez nous
ce que c'est précisément alors
l'avantagé effectivement c'est que nous
sommes d'un centre commercial outlet les
prix sont réduits toute l'année de 30 à
70 % par rapport au prix de référence
des magasins et pendant les périodes de
soldes
une remise supplémentaire s'applique sur
le prix outlet donc il faut l'expliquer
aux clients je pense qu'aujourd'hui
aussi peut-être un sentiment de peur des
clients qui ne comprennent pas le prix
le juste prix alors que nous on lui le
revendiquons l'expliquent on la fiche
dans les vitrines des magasins pour
qu'effectivement le client voit la
cascade de prix et la notion de bon plan
est une réaction sur cette histoire de
juste prix alors c'est à dire oui alors
si vous voulez auparavant il ya quelques
années il ya eu moins de 110 comme on
appelait le prix de référence instant
que c'était le prix en principe qui
étaient communément
un moyen on va dire pour un tel type
d'article qui était le prix du marché on
va dire ça
cette notion de plus de france
maintenant a disparu depuis quelques
années donc il n'y a plus de prix de
référence mais un consommateur il a tant
besoin d'avoir une idée du prix d'un
article
et donc nous en tant qu'associé entre ce
moteur sonné vigilance et on demande aux
consommateurs de bien regarder avant les
soldes
le prix moyen de façon à s'assurer ce
que les prix n'aient pas été gonflé
artificiellement
c'est illégal bon alors j'irai dans le
cadre de la main de physx à ses fils il
a vérifié s'est cassé sur internet c'est
plus compliqué comprenez bien et donc
[Musique]
bien regarder les prix et puis après
achetez comparer en toute connaissance
de pouce vous êtes contrôlés là dessus
sur les soldes vous avez régulièrement
des absolument des contrôles absolument
nous sommes contrôlés
c'est pour ça qu'ils effectivement dans
toutes nos vitrines les prix sont
nettement affiché le prix de référence
est encore d'actualité puisque c'est
celui que l'on affiche
il vient du réseau traditionnel et on
affiche le prix remisait le prix outlet
fils pleurait il ya quand même cet agent
du numérique de cette personnalisation
de la consommation avec les cartes de
fidélité ça change les habitudes de
consommation en fait vous ne vous loguez
servait bien sûr va changer les
habitudes parce que si vous voulez
maintenant les des consommateurs sur des
marchés à domicile via internet où vous
verrez les smartphones moi je bois à
titre personnel actuellement je reçois
des propositions des enseignes avec des
positions de réduction donc c'est vrai
que le le consommateur est beaucoup plus
sensibiliser et d'un semaine c'est vrai
alors qu'est-ce qu'ils l'apprécient
davantage souvent quand c'est notre
anniversaire on reçoit des bons de
réduction en plus
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui plaît
aux consommateurs où il se sent un petit
peu et pied dans sa vie personnelle
il ya quand même une popularité de ses
programmes mais jusqu'où ça peut aller à
votre ami ça après je dirais que c'est
le principe de la vente par internet
vous savez que bon prêt avec avec les
big data il ya des bases de données qui
permettent à des enseignes de contacter
directement les les clients ça je pense
que c'est une évolution qui donnait du
table ça je pense qu'il faut faire avec
bon après ce que l'on pensé que les
consommateurs sont responsables c'est à
eux de choisir leur enseignent leur
centre commercial de bien s'informer
nous on est pour la formation et la
liberté de choix
voilà ces promotions toute l'année ce
sont je me tendent plutôt vers vous pour
les marques une solution de d'encourager
la consommation toute l'année où ça fait
partie d'eux parce qu'on voyait pas ça
avant finalement c'est ces espèces de
d'offres promotionnelles toute l'année
ça fait partie d'une stratégie marketing
quel est l'objectif des marques c'est de
répondre aux besoins du client en fait
parce que le client aujourd'hui on va
pas se cacher aussi qu' un phénomène
encore de difficultés financières et
donc on n'achète plus facilement quand
on a l'impression de faire des affaires
donc recherche comme moi j'ai tout à
l'heure on recherche le bon plan le
grand plan bien sûr c'est une valeur
sûre et on a besoin d'acheter vous dit
tout à l'heure une remise pour
l'anniversaire
il est vrai que pour son anniversaire on
va acheter quelque chose on va recevoir
quelque chose se faire plaisir c'est
aussi offrir une remise au bon moment
d'accord fils pleurait est ce que comme
vous voyez vous l'avenir finalement de
la consommation est-ce qu'on va vers
plus de personnalisation encore est ce
que est ce que les soldes ont ont de
belles années devant elle parce que
rappeler nous c'est assez historique à
sa date du 19e siècle
absolument oui
les grandes des grands magasins se sont
créés à paris
ça y est le bon marché voit sa date de
cette époque qu'un c'est le bon marché
oui c'est bon marché qui avait lancé sa
l'ancêtre du bon marché mais ceux qui
ont marché dimanche au marché voilà en
fait c'était pour redynamiser les
commerces et tenir compte également
aussi du pouvoir d'achat des
consommateurs parce que ce qui est vrai
maintenant c'est que un consommateur ils
regardent de plus en plus les prix et il
va acheter au moment où il ya des soldes
ou des promotions ou des arabes et enfin
de façon ou d'une autre c'est vrai qu'il
va être très sensibles à cela maintenant
il achoppe préférence à ce moment-là
évident ya de bon dans votre centre
commercial vous avez des marques plutôt
haut de gamme
c'est vrai que pour certaines d'entre
elles tout au long de l'année malgré les
offres promotionnelles
voilà les consommateurs n'ont pas
forcément les moyens de les acheter
donc finalement les soldes garde un
intérêt pour ces marques un peu haut de
gamme se dire qu'on va ils vont les
consommateurs ont quand même se déplacer
parce que justement le reste de l'année
c'est compliqué alors le reste de
l'année c'est pas forcément compliqué ce
que nous on est déjà à prix réduit donc
si on si on prend l'exemple d'un
créateur comme courrèges une robe qui
peut être à 1200 euros elle sera à moins
40% à one nation par ims a fait toujours
à peu près 600 euros ce qui ce qui peut
être je suis d'accord mais effectivement
là où on est on cible une certaine
clientèle
à côté de ça le centre offre un
portefeuille de marques de a à z
d'armani à zadig et voltaire en passant
par mango ou actuellement vous pouvez
acheter un petit manteau pour 30 euros
donc je pense qu'effectivement on répond
à la demande
et chacun y trouve son compte qu'elles
ont le profil de vos consommateurs vous
dans votre centre commercial justement
principalement des femmes entre 40 40 et
55 ans et elles viennent de des yvelines
du 92 du 75 et elles viennent parce que
elles font des bonnes affaires elles
reviennent très souvent nous avons été
très étonnés on a pu effectivement
constater quel revenu une fois par mois
une fois par mois et notamment pendant
les soldes et notamment pendant les
soldes d'accord donc ça reste toujours
un moment très intéressant pour vous et
vous ne remarquez pas de désaffection
non du tout les seuls dehors en hiver
2016 ont progressé de 28% en été ont
progressé de 21%
là il est encore trop tôt pour le dire
mais ça démarre sur les chapeaux de roue
philippe le ray sur notre façon de
consommer encore une fois voulez vous
ajouter quelque chose oui ce que je veux
dire c'est que moi ce que je constate
c'est que beaucoup d'enseignés c'est de
fidéliser leurs clients est maintenant
de plus en plus sur ce qu'on achète
il donne des bons de réduction pour un
achat suivant voyez donc à travers cette
méthode il ya cette stratégie les
commerçants une recette en de fidéliser
le client le pire du poteau qui mains
liées bien sûr avec les commerçants mais
il ya cette cette occupation
effectivement du commerce il me semble
est ce que ça vous inquiète d'une façon
ou d'une autre ou vous observez ça avec
distance
non tu entends que donc c'est fait dans
l'esprit de le respect de la loi et que
on offre des produits de qualité à des
prix compétitifs
aucun inconvénient et pour terminer
est-ce qu'on
imagine dans 10 ans tous avec nos
smartphones avant d'entrer dans un
magasin en train de faire apparaître des
bons de réduction est ce que voilà
l'avenir de la consommation sera comme
ça à digitaliser à ce point là ils
devront je pense pas je pense que
aujourd'hui les centres commerciaux
c'est aussi un lieu de vie il ya des
animations il ya un certain nombre de
choses à confort la possibilité touché
un coup de coeur donc je pense
qu'effectivement il n'y aura pas que le
smartphone l'expérience du magasin
ajoute quelque chose il ya quelque chose
de palpable de plus chaleureux que
d'aller faire ses courses on est surtout
dans le prêt-à-porter
oui en effet et puis il faut essayer
aussi ce qui est pas ce qui n'est pas
négligeable
philippe le ray de votre côté vous
imaginez un aspect très digital de la
consommation ballon je pense que tout
dépend des articles pour certains
produits peut-être qu'effectivement on
peut acheter assez facilement sur
internet de la confection c'est quand
même très particulier quand il ya besoin
d'essayer alors après est-ce que ça
passera par différents types de centres
commerciaux en voit comme des évolutions
regardé par les ouvertures le dimanche
par exemple dans certains dans certains
centres commerciaux
donc tout ça on voit bien qu'il ya quand
même des modifications dans le
comportement d'achat des français ça on
le voit mais dans le domaine du du
vêtement je pense que ce sera assez long
aussi à ismaïlia ce besoin proximité
clairement merci à vous deux d'avoir
participé à ce débat et nous on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau sujet merci bonne soirée
[Musique]